the benny jesuits are one of the most
formidable powers in dune this
mysterious sisterhood can see the future
hypnotize others into submission and
pull the strings of power with ease this
is their entire story told across
thousands of years multiple planets and
a whole lot of spice author frank
herbert imagined a world in which a
particular group of powerful women tap
into their powers of creation at the
most primal level they don't just take
control of themselves they take control
of the universe and guide it down a very
specific path while holding no legal
power themselves through rigorous
training and the use of the spice
melange a substance which grants them
tremendous degrees of prescience the
benny gesserate develop incredible
powers of observation control and focus
with these skills they steer kings
powerful families and the common man
towards what they believe to be the
ideal design for the universe
a charitable reading of the benny
jesserot's goals would say they're
seeking stability but in truth what they
are seeking is control over the galaxy's
governmental and economic affairs the
many jesuits insert their followers into
powerful families by a marriage allowing
them to control the movements of the
government's key players the religious
aspects of the benny jesuits emerge
largely from their breeding program a
messianic order they work in the hopes
that their machinations will eventually
lead to the creation of a chosen one
called the quisats hatarak the sisters
of this order contain great powers but
know that there is a portion of
prescience that they cannot reach what
keeps them from this last little bit of
power is their female nature thus they
hope to direct bloodlines until such
time as they can create a male capable
of learning their powers of observation
and control
while the many jesuits mission is spread
by teachers throughout the universe only
adepts trained at the central school by
the most talented leaders called
reverend mothers are deemed fit to marry
into the most critical bloodlines they
are the best of the best and having won
as one's wife is a major status symbol
it's not all etiquette and marriage for
the benny jesserit however they are also
trained in the use of violence and
outright mind control sisters of the
benny jesurite are phenomenally skilled
fighters trained in the weirding way of
combat moreover they are able to control
people with their voice and can shift
the most minute processes in their own
bodies to halt poisons and illnesses
they can also become truth-sayers these
incredibly perceptive women are a
valuable commodity for galactic leaders
as they can detect when a person is
lying
beyond making their trainees desirable
to powerful families via unique skills
the beni jesured also seed prophecies
among people of the galaxy to ease the
implementation of their own goals
throughout the galactic frontier the
benny jesserit missionary spreads
stories of a coming champion who is
remarkably similar to their own cuisates
hatarak this way if the benny jessura's
king of kings appears and the order
attempts to overtake the galaxy the
common people will see it as the
fulfillment of their own religious
beliefs
one will come
the voice from the outer world
bringing the holy war
the so-called missionary of protectable
also provides cover to benny gesserat
followers in the short term should an
adept find themselves on a strange world
or in hostile territory she can feel out
the people around her to see if benny
jesserood ideas have reached that place
a benny jessup familiar with the myths
that have been seated can cast herself
as a prophet or religious teacher to
ensure her own safety these myths are
typically seated only on incredibly
dangerous planets for the benny jesuit
fear that even their advanced powers of
perception and control would not be
enough to stay safe
after centuries of breeding and scheming
the benny jesser would finally stand on
the precipice of creating their messiah
in doom they hope that the lady jessica
atreides will bear a daughter with duke
lido atreides who can then be married to
a son of their rival family the
harkonnens this final bit of stability
and peace coupled with the noble
bloodlines of the two families and the
guidance of the benny jesuit sisters in
both houses will create a son who can be
made into the cuisat's cataract benny
jesuit adapts extreme control over their
bodily processes means that they can
decide whether or not to supply x or y
chromosomes to their unborn child but
lady jessica goes against the ruling of
her benny gesserat elders and opts to
have a son with the duke she deeply
loves him and he wants a male heir to
continue the atreides bloodline this
betrayal coupled with jessica's training
of her young son creates a quissat's
hatarak who is not under the sway of the
benny jesseritt order in fact her son
paul atreides is the worst possible
outcome for the order he's a messianic
figure with god-like powers born to
someone viewed as a traitor
after lady jessica and her son escape an
assassination attempt by the harkonnen
clan they were taken in by desert
dwellers on the planet deracus
colloquially known as dune jessica uses
her knowledge of the missionary of
protectiva to ingratiate herself with
the planet's desert nomads known as
fremen paul's incredible powers
oppressions coupled with her knowledge
of fremen culture and the production of
the planet's all-important spice melange
turned him into a revolutionary figure
on the planet he leads a friendman in a
revolt that threatens to [ __ ] the
production of the galaxy's most
important commodity the quisat's
cataract shows himself to be entirely
outside of any controls placed on him by
the benny jesuit or the galactic empire
rather than allow the spice to be
destroyed the emperor steps down and
paul atreides takes the throne his
friend and warriors carry out a crusade
across the galaxy and paul becomes the
god-king of millions of worlds
seeing their power diminish the benny
jesuit conspired to kill the new emperor
with the help of disgruntled veterans of
his wars and the guild of space
navigators a nuclear attack on the
capital city leaves paul blind but his
prescience allows him to function as if
you can see permanent superstition
around blind people and their harsh
traditions surrounding those who might
slow down a tribe turn paul into a
simultaneously revered and reviled
figure among his most about followers
rather than allow these feelings to
fester paul completes his own messianic
myth by walking out into the desert in
accordance with bremen tradition he
appears to sacrifice himself to show
that he is not above the rules that
govern his people a regeneration of
goodwill takes place which carries over
to his son leto ii over the course of
his 3 500 years as ruler lido ii brings
to benny jesuit to heal by a
tight-fisted control of the spice lido
ii is quite a lot like the benny
jesserot however
he sees that humanity needs to be guided
along the proper route he uses his
complete control of the spice melange to
force various orders and families to
carry out his plans he also
reinvigorates a benny jesuit's breeding
program under his own watch after
becoming a human sandworm hybrid lido ii
follows a similar path to his father he
allows himself to be killed seeing that
it will propel humanity down the path he
has chosen
the many jesuits are very nearly wiped
out by the all-seeing leto the second
however myths and legends like the
missionary of protectora have a funny
way of sticking around for years the
benny jesserood hold on is a diminished
cult and are able to regain a bit of
their power after lido ii allows himself
to be assassinated leto the second's
plan is to suppress the intermingling
and easy travel of the potassia empire
and his brother's own rule siloing off
the many settled worlds in his imperium
over thousands of years reconfigures
humanity as distinct cultures thrive on
far-flung worlds after his death these
disparate cultures begin to interact and
grow beyond the confines of the empire
in a period called the scattering in
forcing humanity to diversify and evolve
lido ii hopes they'll become more able
to face the approaching threats he's
seen in his prescient visions he calls
this way the golden path
and he spoke of the golden path
frightens me
after leto's death the benny jessery
gained access to the spice in a way they
haven't had for thousands of years as
the only presence left in the universe
with a gift of prescience they can see
the contours of the timeline that lido
ii created thus they know that the
tyrant emperor sent humanity on an
intentional path but they have to decide
among themselves whether to carry it
forward
the many chesser would face a complex
choice in the wake of lido ii's death on
the one hand they might reassume control
over the flow of history as they had
before paul atreides changed their plans
forever on the other hand they might
have to follow the ideas of the two men
who did more damage to their order than
any other force person or ruler in the
galaxy they ultimately allow the golden
path to carry on setting their powers on
establishing a world on which they won't
be dependent on noble families and
royals for power though these times are
entirely different for the benny chesser
it's compared to their prior rule many
things haven't changed for them chiefly
the spice is still crucial to their way
of life and is still only available on
the desert planet of auracus the benny
jesuit managed to regain enough
composure to relocate their base of
operations to a new world called chapter
house knowing full well what can come if
someone seizes control of the spice
melange the reverend mothers hatch a
plan to begin a spice operation on their
new planet they are ultimately
successful in bringing a sand worm to
chapter house and begin the spice
production cycle on a world they can
control
setting up spice production on their own
planet might seem like a perfect outcome
for the benny jesseret but things are
not well outside their own planet a new
matriarchal order of powerful adapts
crops up in the far-flung parts of the
galaxy and they are not at all reliant
on the spice to obtain their powers the
honored matres have earned a reputation
as brutes destroying or enslaving nearly
every planet they come across the soft
power of the benny jesuit thus faces a
true threat from a mystical order that
can overpower them in multiple ways
after several encounters with the
leadership of the honored matres the
reverend mothers realize that the matres
are themselves fleeing a destructive
force from outside the known universe
they hatch a plan to ensure the survival
of both orders the highest reverend
mother tells her order to train a
captured matre in the ways of the benny
jesserit after she is fully assimilated
into their program the benny jester at
picker is a champion to fight the leader
of the matress when the matress
commander is defeated the benny jesserod
take control of the enemy faction and
christen it the new sisterhood while
this is technically the end of the benny
cessarid the order carries on in its new
form to fight the revived threat of
artificially intelligent computers
thought to be expelled from the universe
in the buttlery in jihad
the ultimate fate of the benny jesurite
at least as frank herbert intended is
not known in the last full dune book he
wrote chapter house dune the benny
gesserate are consumed with considering
the fate of their aeon's old order
however herbert's final book never makes
clear what exactly the future might hold
it is clear that mysterious god-like
figures who exist outside of the known
universe are about to come into play
nameless powerful entities appear at the
very end of chapter house dune promising
a massive conflict to come in two
sequels reportedly drawn from herbert's
notes on dune 7 his son brian herbert
concludes the story of the benny
jesseret the benny jesuits are able to
restart their breeding program with a
goal entirely opposite to their original
one now they'll work to ensure that
nothing like the cuisat cataract ever
comes back into the universe check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]